all right hop breath averse
welcome back to hot breath the show
where you learn comedy from the pros
i am your host comedian joel byers and
today's guest
is joining us again after our first
interview with him
over four years ago in the hotel of a
lobby
he actually set the standard for what
hot breath is now of a collaborative
community
of comics supporting each other on their
journeys
he was willing to get up at 7am
and do an interview with us in the hotel
lobby
after being up late doing two tapings of
his comedy central special this is a
comic
who cares about comics and helping the
next generation of great comics
which is our entire mission here at hot
breath so without further ado welcome
back to the show
mr roy wood jr everyone let's show them
some love here
and i hear nothing
i hear no claps but i'm sure they're
there
they're there we're here for you buddy
i'm sure they're there
there's a little step what's up man how
you been
i've been good man it's good to
reconnect with you thanks for doing this
yeah absolutely absolutely so i want to
get into
viewer questions but something that
stuck out to me from
our last interview when i went back to
listen to it was just you
really making sure you really emphasize
like collaboration and comedy and
and wanting to like encourage comics to
help each other in their journeys
and i think you doing this is an example
of that but the entire
basically ethos of what we're doing here
is
creating a supportive community of
comics and i'm curious to know
why why is that so important to you that
comics should be helping each other
instead of like competing
because it's more than one tv channel
it's not 1983 where everybody's fighting
for the same two sitcom slots
um you you rise
faster together i don't want to get into
all the african proverb
go together go further whatever
we've heard that said a million times
but
more often or not the people that you're
working shoulder-to-shoulder with those
are the people that are going to be
there
10 years from now if anyone's going to
be there 10 years from now it's going to
be those people
and so you're it's easier to collaborate
like
issa ray said you network across not up
so if you're able to find the people
that are
in your region that are already driven
then you're halfway home but you got to
find people that are
that that have heart and that have real
drive and are serious about this [ __ ]
because
if you don't then you're going to end up
pulling more of the workload
and that's just going to make you bitter
and when i say collaboration it's not
just comedy this is
find the guy with the camera that wants
to direct
find the person that does graphic design
that's looking for things to create
like these are all people within the
ecosystem
and you know i think that it's very very
important find the hungry actor
that just needs something for their real
well now you got a sketch
person that you could cast so i just
think it's about
finding the pockets of the internet
where driven people exist where you
are and [ __ ] reaching out
like this competitiveness of i got to be
the king of the [ __ ]
comedy and i did it all along you'll get
no extra [ __ ] bonus points for doing
it alone and
your [ __ ] money's the same whether
you got a team or not if you're an
executive producer
it's not going to change your check if
there's another executive producer on
the project with you the network just
got to pay more money out
comedy is a lonely journey like how were
you how did you deal with that coming up
in your own comedy hustle like the
lonely times how are you able to
overcome those
i think it's only in the sense of social
in terms of the social structure of the
job
you have friends that don't understand
your family that doesn't understand and
then they're going to give you stupid
solutions to your problems like have you
tried reaching out
to seth meyers maybe he'll put you just
like that's how you get jobs he's just
[ __ ] emailing
show hosts but it doesn't have to be
lonely on
the job side if you can find other
comedians
to even if it's just writing and
bouncing jokes off of each other find
three comics that you aren't similar to
stylistically and that way you know
nobody's gonna steal the [ __ ] joke
and you'll be surprised how many tags
and stuff you can have from just a
little two-hour jail session
of just bouncing jokes off of one
another um
for me you know it was a lot of
playstation that's how i dealt
uh but you know my come up was in the
south
so my first nine years i was a road
comedian so
every week i was working with a
different comic and most of the guys i
started open mic with once we started
featuring
i never saw them again because you just
like
that open mic like those first couple of
years of open mic and being a local
that's like boot camp and then you know
it's a road comic i can't speak to the
coast
or chicago or what that journey is like
in those first five years but
you know down south in the midwest
you're just a [ __ ] nomad
so one week you might be opening for an
a-list act the next week you're opening
for somebody that's been doing it 30
years they're burnt out they're an
alcoholic and they don't give a [ __ ]
about you
so it's not a lot of collaboration
happening
on those particular weekends but i just
think that it's important
to know that what you're doing you're
not alone in doing it and just finding
other people that's the cool thing about
social media you know we didn't have
that when i started in 98 we had a
message board there were two things
we had a website there was a website
called comedy.com
and it had a message board and then
google had a message board
called alt.comedy.standup and it was
just message threads
it was basically og reddit but strictly
for stand-up comedy moderated by
stand-up comedians and so
that was that was how we kept in touch
with each other and just talk [ __ ] about
the road engage just you know find your
tribe as they say
well yeah our facebook group justin
quarantine has grown to over like 2 000
comics all around the world
it's it's been it's been amazing to see
that
the the roots of collaboration and
comedy on the internet like you just
referenced
to see what's possible with it now
that's beautiful
yeah yeah it's really dope it's been
really dope so i i definitely want to
get
people were super excited about you
coming on the show and i definitely want
to make sure we get to some comic
questions here
so um the first one up here we have
william
lombombard asking uh what is your joke
writing process
start to finish and where do you get
your inspiration from
uh second question first i'm inspired by
things that annoy
me no matter how mundane
things that annoy me and things that
people are already
arguing and passionate about so
if i can speak emphatically about
something and make you
feel it's as important to you it should
be as important to you
as it is to me then you can add stakes
to something mundane a great example of
that would be the joke that i did about
um having to pay for an extra sauce it
was a runner and my first special
father figure where it really does annoy
me that you have to pay for an extra
sauce
when you order chicken nugget and you
just go on a journey about that so at
the root of that
is annoyance and from that you know i
try to build stakes
um if i find things that people are
already
arguing about if i can find the third
side to the argument that
no one had considered or had really
talked about
then i have a good place to mine
material and find new perspectives on
the issue that everybody's already
familiar with and i think
that's why i enjoy talking about issues
around the world
more than talking about myself because
i'm talking about things that you
already have an opinion on i already
have your attention
so now it's just a matter of which way
do i want to go
now that i have your attention and so
that became that's probably the biggest
part of
the process especially when i have
writer's block like if i have writer's
block
i watch things that either annoy me or
bore me
i generally speaking i try to watch
30 minutes to an hour a week of
television i try to consume some form of
media for an
hour every week of stuff that i normally
wouldn't [ __ ] with so
one month it might be magazine so i'll
just read guns and ammo
and then a southern living and then
i don't know some computer tech magazine
then i'll read
cosmo kids or just whatever the [ __ ]
just to see what the [ __ ] else is going
on in the world
and more often than not i find that
stuff so boring and so
mundane and so purposeless a lot of the
times
that from that i'm able to find a
premise
you know like like reading the guns and
ammo led to a bit about you know
how much [ __ ] is too much [ __ ] to have
on your gun
and it's all right gun ownership it's
a joke about gun ownership but then
it's a joke about not having the scope
or the laser dot and then the extra clip
and then the shoulder stock and then
like
there's just so much extra [ __ ] you can
put and so
that's a joke about accessorizing and so
then you start trying to parallel a gun
to something that well what's something
that
women love to over accessorize or put
too much razzle dazzle
on and so then that sends you on a
journey through the women's cosmetics
office section of a department store or
reading a women's magazine
to get ideas and inspiration i think
it's important also
uh to research your topics to be
as knowledgeable as to as possible about
the topic if you have an idea about
blank
you should go read about it you should
go watch just
literally an hour a week man if you just
research that [ __ ] 15 minutes a day
that's an
hour by the end of the week and so
that will give you more perspectives on
the issue
and more angles to you know to comment
the topic on
but you know in terms of the writing
process that's probably where i
that's that's kind of where the
inception of most things comes from if
i'm annoyed by it and most people are
already arguing about it then i bet you
i can try and find something funny in
there
and then from there it's just putting it
on stage and wash rinse repeat
you write what you think is funny you go
on stage you say it you come home you
listen to the audio
where did you say too many words all
right cut those words out
is it funnier when you put this punch
line ahead of this punch line
well swap the order this night and i you
know people talk about louis ck
and how he would open with his closer
and so that the rest of his comedy set
is a declining action forcing him to
over perform
the subsequent jokes which boosts those
jokes
and then reshuffling the order of the
set but i think you could take that
concept and still apply
within an actual joke itself but the
funniest part up front
if it works sequentially and the logic
still tracks
and then that'll force you to find other
stuff and you know after like three four
months of running a bit regularly
when i say regularly i mean like every
week somewhere at the end of that
you know what the form of the joke is
gonna be and then from there
you can just start working through the
ordering of the joke all right i know
what all the funny parts are now what
order do i want to tell a man and then
boom that joke is done
and then you do the next joke and the
next joke in the next joke
and i go through that whole process and
then when i'm putting together an
hour set then it's about figuring out
the sequencing because some jokes work
better behind other jokes you know
yeah when we had jeff foxworthy on here
and he talked about his hours set
he breaks down into specific like
categories
or topics will you try to chunk your
material into specific
like topics like that yeah it depends
like if i have a call back or something
that i'm trying to yo-yo back to then
you know
maybe so um you know there's a
there's a long run that i'm working on
now
um but this is a perfect example of
research
so the the basic gist of the joke is
just in how
how unsung white actors are
in black struggle movies and how to have
a
good black to have an effective black
movie
that tells a painful story for you to
really feel pain
you need a white actor on screen
that is just [ __ ] being horrible
you need a horrible vile [ __ ] to
really tell this story the right way and
so then you go through examples of
movies where white people
went above and beyond to be terrible and
you treat them like unsung heroes and
that's the juxtaposition
of that joke but that joke is also to a
bigger narrative
about the perception of black struggle
and then from there i'm going into
the relationship between black people
and afro brits and black people and
caribbeans and black people and
native africans in the whole black
diaspora but i'm starting from that
place of
that joke to establish the world because
the way we perceive
black pain is through the eyes of
american movies
so it's how american movies
how black american pain is put in one
place but we don't know as much or how
is black
pain portrayed for afro brits for
caribbeans for native africans
so it's an encompassing chunk about
how black people are perceived based on
the media that you consume about them
that nine times out of ten they're not
even in charge of
so that's the bigger 15 minutes
but right now all i got is that six
minute chunk
about white people in those movies and
white savior movies and stuff like that
and
it's a bit that i have to work because
the further we get away from particular
movies
the less people remember them so i have
to be able to do this
this joke was kind of percolating after
green book
right and the whole green book moonlight
controversy
but now if i say green book you kind of
gotta squint for a second to remember
the movie and remember the plot
so now i have to decide whether to drop
green book
or add three minutes of material where i
recap what the [ __ ] happened
in green book if you didn't see it and
so that has to be
funny but not be too much of a
digression
off of a cliff if you know what i'm
saying like the same thing with like
shape of water and how that was
essentially a white savior movie
like that you know only it was a fish
[ __ ] like that was the punch line that
i used to use
this white lady saved the fish [ __ ] and
that but as we got further and further
away from shape of water
it's two is too long ago you know so
it's about creating a joke that captures
the tone of the times but not
it's like it's you have to joke about
the climate and not the weather
if that makes sense so yeah it's a joke
that started on a spec that's based on a
specific
incident or a specific film but now we
need to look at the totality
of black film and black cinema which
means going all the way back to the
[ __ ] 90s
and would i have time i mean i don't
always watch a whole film but if i'm
doing
jokes about movies it doesn't hurt to
watch the movie again
or just watch the like there's this um
is it called cine clips or movie clips
there's a youtube channel
that just has like the 10 or 11 best
moments from a film
just all in a playlist multiple movies
so even if you've never seen the movie
you can watch
multiple you know [ __ ] whatevers
about a particular film and that will
help because it'll be
it'll spark something and then you'll
see two three things and that you didn't
think connect
and then you go oh [ __ ] that [ __ ]
connects
so now you're doing this whole run about
white savior movies
and how the green book was this white
savior movie where
this white person was driving around a
person of color
and blah blah blah blah and then you
start looking at the rest of the
landscape of interracial
of any film with interracial leads right
and you go what else can i compare the
green book to and it took a minute to
kind of go through
the catalog of interracial starring
films and you know the lethal weapons
and the
[ __ ] trading places and 48 hours and
[ __ ] like that right
and then i settle on oh [ __ ] if you look
at the end of the first
the first fast and furious movie fast
and furious is a white savior film
walker gave a person of color the keys
to his car
so he could get away from the cops
he [ __ ] said it like and so then
it's about taking that scene in the fast
and furious
and if i want i might do this as a
sketch but just putting like negro
spiritual music under it
yeah and treating it like
it's no different than the green book in
that regard it's the white person
helping this
this [ __ ] mexican german
whatever vin diesel is looking criminal
like that type of you know that that
type of stuff you know
um it's just exploring
you know the the bit about
the national anthem and how black people
don't write
this is a good example of just
researching right
so i had a bit in
my first special about how black people
don't um [ __ ] i just lost my training i
thought black people don't
the the whole bit was about the national
anthem and black people should kneel
black people should kneel for the anthem
but black people have never been
patriotic case in point
no black person has ever written a
patriotic song we do covers
but we don't write original songs about
america
so then you start going through all of
these
hit songs and i started noticing the
consistent theme
was oh [ __ ] black people rap about
specific cities they don't talk about
they don't talk about america they talk
about pockets of america
where they can have a good time and so
you had ray charles georgia on my mind
you had will smith
um you know miami you had welcome to
atlanta by jermaine dupree and ludacris
and then it came to living in america by
james brown
and it feels like a song about america
but then
as i'm looking at the lyrics at the end
of the song
he starts naming specific cities and so
the punchline in that joke was that
he tricked white people into thinking
the song was about america but at the
end of the song it's a secret message to
black people
letting them know are the 10 cities
where you can live and so that i don't
get
i don't get to that punch line without
actually going and researching where i
could have just left it at the
generality or just black people don't
talk about
america we written on them songs yeah
anyway next joke if you can support your
thesis with
research then you are a much better
journalist you know a much better
scientist
but how much research like how many
songs do you have to
explore before you pick like the best
three like what what would you say is
like your average between how many ideas
i have
versus actually make it to the final
like special
wait repeat that one more time that you
kind of cut out a little bit
so like how many how much research
goes into it like you pick those songs
but how many songs do you have to
explore before you
pick the ones that are worth keeping
you have to pick the ones that are
popular and then you also have to figure
out where people are going to
push back on your thesis because we live
in an argumentative and opinionated
culture now so
i have to already know what you're going
to say about what i'm saying
and have something prepared for that
because everything
you know the first thing anyone and i
threw this around with a couple of
friends you know i bounce theories off
of
other comedians as well
and hey man what do you think about this
bit black people don't write patriotic
songs we talk about cities
yeah but what about living in america
that's patriotic
and i go yeah but james brown didn't
write that yeah but don't nobody know
that they just know that he did it so
it's his song no one cares about
songwriting i thought that's a fair
point
so now i have to figure out a way to
still uphold my thesis
while inserting living in america and
thank god
the lyrics saved you know saved that bit
but you know there's sometimes so you'll
do research and you won't get [ __ ]
i mean we're just talking about the bits
that are kept we're not talking about
the ones that
that get dropped and don't and they get
stuck in mud
that don't necessarily
go from here to here you know
because you can have it and it's like
like there's a there's a bit that i'm
trying to work about mass shootings i'm
not sure if i'm going to be able to do
it anymore because of what chappelle did
with his snl monologue regarding how
uh covet how the pandemic curbed mass
shootings
but you know the joke worked a lot but
this is terrible to say
but the joke worked a lot better when
mass shootings were more of a regular
occurrence in our country because they
were at the forefront
of people's minds but now they aren't we
still know about mass shootings but
they're not as publicized because we're
in an election year and you got all the
pandemic [ __ ] and it's only
30 minutes in a newscast so
that joke which i thought was climate
because there were so many mass
shootings happening over the past five
to ten years right there was a good two
or three a year
enough to where i could comfortably walk
on stage and say mass shooting
and know that people would be with me
immediately where now
that was then the climate has changed
you know maybe it'll be different you
know once the
once the [ __ ] uh vaccine hits or
whatever
but i think for the most part that's a
bit that i'm gonna have to figure out a
way to retool
to get back into it you know and
and i think it's for where that joke is
right now
it's a long walk to make a point that
i'm not even sure is worth even making
anymore
just in terms of how
the bit the bit as a whole is about
why racial profiling is good
and you start with that juxtaposition up
front
and then you work your way back to
justified and how
you have oh there's another thing it
also ties in all the caring [ __ ] and
just white people calling the police on
anybody looking suspicious and so
the basic premise that i'm trying to
drive towards is just about how if
you're going to profile
someone profile if you want to stop mass
shooting start profiling the people who
have these [ __ ] up haircuts
8 out of 10 mass shooters have a [ __ ]
up haircut
so and when mass shootings happen the
first thing we do
is talk to his parents
and ask them why didn't they stop it
don't talk to his parents
talk to the barber the barber knew the
barber is the one
and and so the whole bit is just about
blaming mass shootings on barbers
gotcha perfectly fine bit pre-coveted
perfectly fine but that's
right now that joke feels like a walk
so it'll get sent down to aaa and maybe
we'll strip it for parts and it'll fit
into something else
but it's not a bit like if i started
going back on stage tomorrow
and building my hour i don't think i
would
i don't think i would do that bit the
part of the and so
and so here's where [ __ ] gets [ __ ] up
right
so because i lose that part of the bit
the other part of the mass shooting bit
that is actually relevant and pertinent
and
is climate isn't strong enough because
the barber [ __ ]
was the [ __ ] at the end gotcha
because the whole front half of the bit
is about so
without doing the bit essentially so my
child
bit someone in school but it was a
retaliation bite
from another incident at school right
and when you're the parent of a child
that does something wrong
the school scrutinizes you as if you
taught your child to be violent
and you could do everything right as a
parent and your child still might
[ __ ] up and it instantly made me feel
sympathy for the parents of every mass
shooter
and so in that bit what i'm essentially
doing
is going through most of the mass
shootings that have happened in this
country
and looking at how the parents were
treated in each
mass shooting and so when we talk about
research i had to go dig in the crates
almost 20 years in mass shootings in
this country and go
look the kid the kid at virginia tech um
the asian kid who shot up everybody at
virginia tech
uh 15 20 years ago his parents
literally did everything they possibly
could
to keep him out of trouble they sent him
the programs they
sent him to make sure that he was
talking to people
psychiatrist therapist he was doing all
of that [ __ ]
before he went and killed so the
there's this this idea that every kid
is hiding guns under the bed and mama
don't know
is fault so that's the argument i'm
trying to make in that bit
it's just about how we can talk about
mass shootings
but mass shooting good mass shooting bad
gun control no gun control here's the
third angle
all right mass shootings whatever but
can we stop acting like
every single parent is the one who drove
the kid to the [ __ ] gunshot
wow and that's the angle that i choose
to approach mass shootings
gotcha and so but you support that
thesis
with examples of where parents do
there's a [ __ ] ton of parents who are
fuck-ups
the kid who drove over in wisconsin and
killed two
um two uh black lives matter protesters
with the ar15 drove over from illinois
whatever
his mama was the one that drove him to
there's definitely some [ __ ] up
parents
but that's not like i like every single
time it's the parent because here's the
shooting
the parents were doing this here's this
shooting the parents did this
here and so there was there was a
[ __ ] there's a there was a mass
shooter i think it was in pittsburgh it
wasn't the synagogue
um it was a couple of months ago i mean
a couple of years ago
this guy was like [ __ ] 50 he was 46 i
think he was 46
when he um when he shot everybody right
and people were still trying to blame
his mom and
i'm like she's [ __ ] 70 bro like
she got him to 46. she did her job
you can't like you can't
[ __ ] blame her you can't blame a 70
year old for some [ __ ] a 46 year old
dead
that ain't how the game's supposed to go
but i don't get that
i don't get that punch line unless i go
and do all that goddamn research
but even still all of that stuff it's
just
a couple of funny quips because you're
still dealing with dead bodies you're
still saying the word mass shooting
which is just a [ __ ]
word for people but the barbershop [ __ ]
is the funniest part of that bit
all right and in my opinion the
barbershop [ __ ] doesn't work so if the
barbershop [ __ ] don't work
all that parenting [ __ ] got to go down
to aaa too until we can get a better
button
on the end of that whole run so
some jokes are great but they're just
not ready or just doesn't
fit you know it maybe it's the type of
joke when there's another mass shooting
that's the joke that i can [ __ ]
reassemble real quick and just throw up
online
from a club set not everything's gonna
be on tv and be polished some shit's
gotta just be
some chappelle 846 type [ __ ]
i hope that breaks down the process a
little more you know that's kind of but
that's kind of how i
try to construct [ __ ] oh yeah i mean you
just put on a writing master class right
there my friend
yeah thanks for sharing all that behind
the scenes that's some the side of
comedy people don't see
is we're people just on stage talking
and they're like
no i actually wrote like an entire
thesis to get five minutes of material
you know it's like yeah some parents do
the right thing and kids still [ __ ] up
here are the examples and you have a
punch line
to go with [ __ ] each example but then
after that observation you have to have
some sort of
solution or conclusion and the
conclusion i have is no longer timely
due to the conversation in the zeitgeist
so that joke is [ __ ] so let's switch
gears
into just pursuing comedy in general and
um
we've got like uh
five minutes left here so let's do a
rapid fire
for some of these questions here we have
about 60 comics watching live which is
great
um so uh christian williams
how did you make the choice to jump into
comedy as a full-time career from
an occasional hobby um
i had an advantage in that i started at
19 so i never
knew anything other than being broke but
if you already have an income and rent
and bills
it's hard so figure out a way to
monetize on the internet
and it's going to be hard to travel i
don't even think comedy clubs are going
to be traveling features
and if they are they're not going to
give them hotels anymore so
you know that's where networking with
other comedians in the area and couch
surfing
might come into play um but for me it
was easy
i started when i was still in college so
when i came out of college i just
kept doing gigs like i never had to make
more than 350 a month to cover my
expenses until i was like 22 or 23.
um if you're doing it now you've got to
supplement income if you're on the road
figure out some day labor figure out
some tip service [ __ ]
you know whatever you can do to stretch
a dollar but i think the smarter way in
building an audience which is ultimately
what's going to get you leveraged
now in the industry is to figure out
ways to do that online that honor your
creative sensibilities don't become
something you aren't just for the sake
of building a following but
you know just look at it
steve rogers asking uh what's your
advice for someone who is
one late night under their belt and
trying to do the next step
um oh that's a whole separate podcast
right
there um
the next move would be trying to find
representation but first identify what
it is you want to do
more often than not nobody's giving [ __ ]
to anybody that doesn't have a following
or an audience
and if you're just being funny
repeatedly at the local level
and traveling to do feature work and
stuff like that
that's fine but just i would look at all
road comedy as a gym the concept of
grinding for 10 to 15 years
and doing late night every year
sebastian miniscalco style
or jake johansen i'm trying to think of
some other guys that came up on the road
more so than traditional casted sitcom
stuff
i think that [ __ ] is dead so if you've
already done late night you're ahead of
the curve
so find the festivals from the festivals
you can find
representation or you have to figure out
creative ways to put your [ __ ] online
and then that'll bring people to you
just shoot me a dm or something on that
that's that's a
that's a much more i i have to ask you
questions first before i could even
answer that question
like squarely
uh let's see maybe like two more here
yeah keep firing if it's all comedians
just
cut it off but anybody that's already
threw up a question man let's answer
that [ __ ]
all right yeah let's run them then while
the boy is still asleep i
will be up soon yeah i knew you were
sneaking
the child to do this so i appreciate
that yeah at the time the nap
perfectly
so oz morris um how often do you write
and how do you balance writing for daily
show versus writing for your stand-up
daily show is a little easier because
you're just addressing one
issue and you the depths and layers
to which you can explore stuff on stage
we don't have the time to do
on the daily show like we're working on
a piece right now there's school
teachers that are making a quarter of a
million dollars
on youtube doing homeschooling videos
for youtube subscribers so there's a lot
of school teachers during the pandemic
who are making triple what they made in
the classroom for half the work
and way more appreciation so one of the
teachers is like [ __ ] it i'm never going
back
and the other teacher's like you know
what i'm gonna go back because in person
learning is the best
so that's just a conversation between
two influencers and the joke is just
treating them like
influencers if i did that on stage it
would be about
all of the jobs that became remote and
the effects of covet
on traditional employment and how things
became remote which means that's a deep
dive into
what are all of the [ __ ] jobs that
became remote
and what were the ripple effects of the
quarantine or those forms of employment
so you got to read a forbes you gotta
read a wall street journal you gotta
read the new york times
to just see who pivoted and did what
and all of that [ __ ] right so
that would be the two different ways
that i would have approached that like
if i were doing that teacher bit on
stage
it would be part of a bigger
conversation but just for the daily show
it's just for that
uh morgan's asking uh morgan carroll
how do you vet jokes without a state
i haven't you know i'll bounce premises
off friends but you ain't got [ __ ] till
you put it on stage that's why i think
the zoom stuff
like i've only done
maybe five or six zoom shows total
since april stylistically it doesn't
work for me
but i did enjoy hearing laughs and it's
at least a com
it's at least confirmation that i'm on
to something
um twitter twitter is a good place
to confirm whether or not your joke is
clever like i can reverse engineer a
joke
through twitter where
i'll have a thought i think it's clever
and then i'll go on twitter and search
for keywords within that ideology to see
if anybody else thought of it and if
somebody else has
normally it's a bunch of people all
making the same joke and then i go okay
that's another
that's not a good joke because that's a
joke that if you make it on stage
everybody watching is going to be
thinking ahead of you
and beat you to your own punch line that
mean it's a bad joke it just means that
becomes part of a premise
to something that has to be a little bit
more
a little bit more depth social media
lacks depth
the it pedals in generalities but it's a
good place to see whether or not your
train of thought
is predictable or not so i'll vet a
premise
you know that way to help me you know
strike out whether or not it's worth the
trouble
uh angel angel perez
how do you control your ego um how do
you keep yourself grounded
so you can stay objectionable and keep
your edge
well i try not to have an ego i think
you have to have an arrogance about
yourself when you go on stage you have
to be arrogant enough to believe that
what you have to say is so important
that everybody has to shut the [ __ ] up
to hear it
there's arrogance in that but i don't
know
i've worked with enough comics who used
to have the juice that don't have the
juice no more
and not wanting that for myself is
more than enough to try and keep me
humble because the people that are
coming up behind you are the ones that
are eventually going to leapfrog you
that's inevitable you leapfrogged and
then you get leapfrogged and
the goal for me at least once
tv is done [ __ ] with me on camera
is to try to create and write content
and produce content and if not that at
least tour you know you look at a
[ __ ] like sinbad sinbad
hasn't been with the exception of the
sitcom
rail on fox before that sinbad wasn't on
tv on a regular enough basis
but his entire career he sells tickets
every year
as if the [ __ ] was on tv
yesterday and i believe i truly believe
a lot of that
is from being kind and of course being
funny
but just never carrying yourself with an
air of arrogance you know
treat other comedians as your peers and
not your peons
you'll be all right uh let's do
two more here um this is something a lot
of people have been asking
basically when it comes to storytelling
how much of a story like how do you know
when to twist a true story to make it
funnier on stage like bouncing
truth and funny in a story
um i think you tell the story one way
true and then i think you go back
through
and then you add details and paint the
picture i was talking about ali sadiq
about this [ __ ] last night
um i'll find i'll find the pdf
but if you think of a story like read
and this is where reading magazine
articles can help because like those
long form magazine
articles like you ever read like a gq gq
is really good for this playboy too
the first paragraph will just be i'm
i settled into a west soho restaurant
seat to meet with jerry seinfeld this
would be my fourth time talking to him
and i looked out the window
and their seinfeld appeared in a scarf
that perfectly matched the seats of the
porsche that he was getting out of
it was double parked he didn't care and
like it's all of this [ __ ] that's just
extemporaneous but if you're telling
that story on stage
the sounds the smells the
the crunch of the burger if you're
describing food jim gaffigan is a great
person
to watch when it comes to the
descriptiveness
of something and i think in a story the
more you can
the more you can describe the more
you're putting into people's heads
what is there and then people are then
going to put their own funniest version
of what you're saying in their head
so he had a head like a watermelon well
was it a vertical watermelon
or oval horizontal water
they're gonna they're gonna do the rest
of the heavy lifting for you
on that i you know you can add a lot of
craziness but
you know it's just a matter of you know
how wild of a story do you want
but i think the fact that the story is
true
is already real enough and crazy enough
i would recommend watching this
is not happening streaming
on youtube um
i'm trying to think of some good
storytellers on that show uh
jim norden is good jim norden
and ali sadiq are pretty good
roseanne had won one season i don't
think it was my season but she told a
good story drew carey too
but it's just you know you could say
so-and-so i'm from cleveland and
so i did a show in cleveland and we're
at the club
and the guy comes up versus blah blah
blah
i'm from cleveland have you ever been to
cleveland this city
just the smell of it just the
there's there's a river that just goes
through it and then there's a guy
and it's founded by a guy named [ __ ]
john like how the [ __ ] did you name city
this dude named john named his own city
cleveland like what the
like whatever that whatever that
digression is you want to go down
however far off track you want to go
that's where the places for extra funny
are to punch up something that's already
true
i love it and uh the final one here we
have from cameron
saying do you have any idea of what
comedy will look like in a year
everyone's leaving new york and la and
it's clear
that it's a huge shift in how comics
make it yeah i think the concept of just
being in the city
and waiting for a manager to find you
that's probably gone but you know i hear
everybody's going
uh austin nashville atlanta
uh i'm hearing some seattle and denver
rumblings as well
um i think that it's going to just
you're going to have bustling
communities but
no matter where you live the fight is
going to be finding your audience and
creating an audience because that's how
you're going to tour
it's the only way you're going to tour
and make money is if you have people
that are
excited to come see you if they're just
excited to come see
comedy the book is going to book
somebody regional
or you're going to have to drive
yourself there and they're not going to
pay you dick
for you to come and grow your craft and
if you're doing that which is fine
that's what i did for a damn near decade
you have to figure out other ways to
supplement your income
i looked up i sold merch after shows i
also worked in morning radio morning
radio
paid my bills and gave me a little bit
of health care while i was out
for four days 500 minus gas
you know so there's no science to it
um i think you're also going to have to
figure out
places to create more stages for
yourself but i think a lot of these
markets you know
young and have already you know they're
doing that pretty heavy
i'm 41 so when i say young i mean like
25s and under
who kind of came up in a different you
know comedic ecosystem
where the indie scene was already
established and so you could do
some weird bar show at the end like i
think
david perdue in atlanta has like a a 1
a.m
it's a show that starts at 2 a.m with
some [ __ ] it's the weirdest [ __ ] [ __ ]
and i show up and it's packed and i'm
like
all right i guess we're telling jokes at
two in the morning
yeah yeah and so but that only happens
if he
pioneered that instead of just waiting
to do open mic every monday at the punch
line i sure hope this comedy club
chooses me
[Music]
comedy club ain't the gatekeepers
they're just one of many avenues don't
give them any more [ __ ]
leverage than they deserve what you need
is stage time
and repetition and an audience and
whoever the [ __ ] will give you that now
will happily have you back when you have
an audience all of this [ __ ]
about well i'm not gonna book you if you
work that club across town
[ __ ] off go across town build that
audience and see if that [ __ ]
don't call you
and go you should do your night at my
club and i'll give you a better cut
well do you have any closing advice for
comics out there some favorite advice
you've picked up over the years
i think i've i've given it all
i don't i don't have anything else just
[ __ ]
above all be nice and collaborate with
other people don't steal
material and if someone steals your joke
don't get into a facebook argument with
them about it call them like a [ __ ]
man
and trucking or an adult
pardon me um and squash that [ __ ]
um yeah i think that's it
cool well the final thing so we'll stop
there yeah
guests do is uh would you mind looking
into the camera saying your name
and why comics should listen to hot
breath
um i'm roy with junior comics should
listen to hot breath because
it's comics talking about comedy we're
your co-workers you piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] let us help
amen well hop breath first give it up
for roy wood junior everyone thank you
roy for coming back on the show my man
have a good night out there good luck
y'all on the road
bye
i'm sure he's waking up now
you